[Applaus]
[Musik]
was alles kommt euch in den sinn wenn
ihr von thailand wird ich nehme an
paradiesische strände wunderschöne
korallenriffe und einige der schärfsten
lebensmittel der welt gut aber fällt
euch auch etwas aus thailand ein was man
auf der ganzen welt jeden tag nutzt ein
echter exportschlager dieses tropischen
landes nein nein nein wir sprechen hier
nicht über die beliebten massagesalons
sondern über einen wesentlichen
bestandteil jedes computers etwas das so
wichtig ist dass thailand weltweit in
die schlagzeilen gerät wenn es solche
dinge passieren
[Musik]
vorher in der überflutungen in thailand
gefährden die versorgung mit festplatten
der guardian 2011
diese nachricht mag zwar aus dem jahr
2011 stammen aber eines könnt ihr mir
getrost glauben die ganze welt ist immer
noch von thailand festplattenproduktion
abhängig wenn nicht sogar mehr als je
zuvor so gut wie alle unternehmen alle
youtuber wie zum beispiel visual politik
und auch du nutzen täglich festplatten
aus thailand denn das asiatische land
mit 71 millionen einwohnern ist eine
unbekannte riesige produktions
drehscheibe für elektronik aus der 40
prozent aller weltweit hergestellten
festplatten laufen gekommen und das ist
zunächst überraschend denn trotz teil
aus wachsender wirtschaft und großer
industriekapazitäten handelt es sich um
einen schockierend instabiles land seit
den 1930 er jahren gibt es in thailand
durchschnittlich alle vier jahre einen
putsch das ist weit entfernt von einer
geregelten demokratie die menschenrechte
werden oft missachtet es gibt keine
meinungsfreiheit und
majestätsbeleidigung kann einen leicht
ins gefängnis bringen und es ist eines
der länder in denen der könig noch
konkubinen haben darf trotz alldem
genießen die thailänder ein ähnlich
hohes einkommensniveau wie die chinesen
sie haben eine überraschend egalitäre
gesellschaft so gut wie keine
arbeitslosigkeit und eine niedrige
inflationsrate
natürlich sind sie nicht so reich wie
die schweizer aber sie haben es viel
besser als beispielsweise ihrer
nachbarin wird dann und nein
thailand verfügt nicht über große
rohstoffvorkommen wie erdöl oder gold
das auf gar keinen fall
deshalb lautet die heutige frage wie
kann es der wirtschaft in einem so
turbulenten und repressiven land ist so
gut gehen auf welche weise ist es zu
einem so wichtigen industriestandort
geworden und schließlich wieso sind die
weltwirtschaft youtuber du und ich in
genau diesem moment überhaupt so
abhängig von festplatten aus thailand
heute werden wir die alle diese fragen
natürlich beantworten aber bevor wir das
tun wollen wir wie immer einen blick
zurück in die geschichte der
[Musik]
im land der blinden
man muss nicht lange studiert haben um
expertin thailändischer monarchie zu
werden im grunde genommen muss man sich
noch einen einzigen namen merken und
damit zählen könnte der aktuelle könig
ist rama der zehnte davor gab es könig
rama den neunten sein vater war wie du
wahrscheinlich schon erraten hast rama
der achte und so geht es immer weiter
zurück bis zum ersten rama und ok ich
weiß was du isst einwänden wird zehn
generationen mag sagtest du nicht gerade
das thailand instabil ist wie kann es
sein dass dann seid 237 jahren die
gleiche herrscher familie an der macht
ist
tatsächlich war thailand seit dem jahr
1932 schauplatz zwölf erfolgreiche
putsche und sieben gescheiterter
putschversuche
meistens ging es dabei um machtkämpfe
zwischen verschiedenen fraktionen der
armee untereinander wobei die autorität
des monarchen stets respektiert wurde
also ja die regierung wechselt aber
nicht der könig und egal welche
regierung nach einem putsch an die macht
kommt jede behält diese klassisch
thailändische art von militärischen
autoritarismus bei
doch die großen bastionen der demokratie
konnten noch nie ganz der versuchung
widerstehen mit ihnen brutal und
autoritär regierten ländern 2 für das
starke wirtschaftswachstum thailand sind
nämlich vor allem westliche
investitionen verantwortlich denkt nur
an die vereinigten staaten in den
siebziger jahren
sie brauchten einen partner in der
region und nun schaut euch mal diese
karte aus jener zeit an
wir haben sehr kambodscha das im
wesentlichen ein ort des kommunistischen
kraus war in numbers ebenfalls
kommunistisch und befand sich im krieg
laos hat keinen zugang zu sehen und ist
auch kommunistisch indonesien war
instabil und hochproblematisch und dann
burma das bis vor kurzem eines der am
stärksten isolierten länder der welt war
im grunde gab es also nur ein land mit
dem die usa eine partnerschaft eingehen
kunden und das war teil eine große hilfe
dabei war dass die könige von thailand
und ihrer militärischen anführer immer
glühende antikommunisten waren und so
wurde thailand ein natürlicher
verbündeter für die vereinigten staaten
und japan während des kalten krieges
aber wir reden hier nicht nur über
politik wenn es um die wirtschaft geht
hat thailand einen erstaunlichen vorteil
von denen die meisten menschen nichts
wissen
[Musik]
eine überraschend stabile währung ja der
bat die thailändische währung ist eine
der stabilsten währungen der welt bis in
die siebziger jahre war er an den dollar
gekoppelt und das ist ein großer vorteil
für investoren denn egal was passiert
das geld das diese dort investiert wird
immer seinen wert behalten das ist viel
besser als das was viele andere länder
anbieten konnten und dann ist da noch
der tourismus bis 1967 empfängt thailand
bereits über 330.000 touristen pro jahr
hauptsächlich aus ländern wie japan
australien und den vereinigten staaten
[Musik]
mit anderen worten das fragwürdige
politische system teil 1 wurde toleriert
da es in der region sozusagen der
einäugige unter den blinden war und
dadurch der beste ort um dort sein geld
auszugeben und seine zeit zu verbringen
und das erklärt die enormen
investitionen die die vereinigten
staaten um diesen land getätigt haben so
bauten sie zum beispiel eine ganze
autobahn von 510 kilometer länge welche
für die thailändische regierung ein
ordentlicher kick start war um mit dem
bau der infrastruktur in eigenregie zu
beginnen dank dieser tatsache ist das
land heute in der region
infrastrukturell führend wenn ihr jetzt
aber denkt teil als bester freund wäre
damals die usa gewesen weit gefehlt
japans engagement war noch viel viel
größer damals begann japan damit eine
eigene internationale agenda zu
entwickeln damals entstand das paradigma
der st
grundsätzlich ging es japan um seine
wirtschaftliche schlagkraft in der
region zu erhöhen
so begann sowohl die privatwirtschaft
als auch die japanische regierung in
südostasiatischen ländern zu investieren
und um es euch noch mal in erinnerung zu
rufen in dieser zeit gab es in der
region einfach keinen besseren ort um
sein geld zum investieren als thailand
es war einfach zur richtigen zeit am
richtigen ort angebot trifft nach habe
in gewisser weise war thailand für japan
das was mexiko für die usa und ich weiß
was du jetzt denkst mag erzählt uns
jetzt eine weitere gute nacht geschichte
von einem armen armen land das die
reichen kapitalistischen traumprinzen
mit kusshand empfängt und wenn sie nicht
gestorben sind leben sie noch immer in
einer glücklichen nachbarschaft zusammen
nicht wahr
nun eigentlich nicht tatsächlich ist das
gegenteil der fall
zu dieser zeit war thailand unglaublich
protektionistisch in den 1970 er jahren
gab es auf einige waren die alkohol
schuhe und autos völlig von bis zu 90
prozent und staatlich regulierte preise
bei regulären waren üblich schließlich
war thailand nur ein weiteres
billiglohnland aber dann in den 80er
jahren passierte etwas was großen
einfluss auf dieses land hatte
[Musik]
ein fest für festplatten die allerersten
personal computer wurden in den
siebziger jahren auf den markt gebracht
aber der eigentliche boom begann in den
80er jahren künstlich hatte jeder
büroangestellte seinen eigenen computer
die leute kauften sich auch ein zuhause
da sie sich im büro an seine bedienung
gewöhnt hatten nun und welche länder
führten diese technologische revolution
den boom der pc-industrie an natürlich
waren es die vereinigten staaten und
japan unternehmen wie apple commodore
ibm.com pack oder sharp nominierten den
pc-markt in seiner anfangszeit
[Musik]
walter setzte ein starker wettbewerb um
bessere und billigere modelle ein es
mussten auf jeden fall kosten gespart
werden und es gab eine pc komponente
welche im gegensatz zu mikrochips keine
hochqualifizierten arbeitskräfte für
ihre herstellung erfordert die
festplatte und welches land ergab sich
letztlich aus der beste standort für die
produktion von festplatten nun ein land
das eine verbindung zu einem der
wichtigsten pc hersteller hatte ein land
das bereits über industrie und gute
infrastruktur verfügte und dieses land
war natürlich thailand dies erklärt
warum ist die g technology eine der
führenden festplatten firmen bereits
1973 ihrer erste fabrik in thailand
eröffnete aber dies war nicht die erste
firma die sich dort niedergelassen hat
während der 80er jahre
nach einigen weiteren staatsstreichen
hatte thailand die meisten seiner zelle
massiv gesenkt
[Musik]
sie öffneten sich dem internationalen
handel und dies hat dann viele andere
unternehmen dazu veranlasst den beispiel
von seagates zufolge erinnert ihr euch
an den sogenannten netzwerkeffekt wir
haben darüber viele male auf bis über
politik gesprochen sobald man eine
kritische masse von unternehmen einer
bestimmten branche hat entsteht ein eng
geknüpftes netzwerk aus lieferanten
universitäten und spezialisierten
fachkräften
im jahre 1993 nahm beispielsweise
hitachi seine tätigkeit in thailand auf
und verfügt dort heute über 40
tochtergesellschaften und 16.000
mitarbeiter
das bedeutet dass sie alle benötigten
materialien für die herstellung von
festplatten in thailand in großen mengen
kaufen können was dem unternehmen hohe
einsparungen ermöglicht seagate
beschäftigt derzeit über 11.000
mitarbeiter in dem land welche 50
millionen festplatten pro jahr
produzieren und die hälfte aller
festplatten von toshiba kommt aus
thailand thailand ist für ganze 40
prozent der weltweiten
festplattenproduktion verantwortlich das
entspricht einem wert von etwa 12
milliarden dollar pro jahr
[Musik]
und jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht ist
das denn für thailändische verhältnisse
viel geld nun es macht 2,6 des
thailändischen bruttoinlandsprodukts aus
bezogen auf deutschland ist dieser
anteil etwa so groß wie die ganze
energieversorgungsbranche und in
thailand mit einem einzigen produkt
festplattenlaufwerken jetzt werden
einige von euch natürlich einwenden dass
eine derart hohe abhängigkeit einer
ganzen volkswirtschaft von nur einem
einzigen produkt doch ein enormes risiko
darstellt außerdem werden in immer mehr
pcs und notebooks noch gar keine
mechanischen festplattenlaufwerke mehr
verbaut sondern nur noch ssd ist und
deren chips werden doch in china und
südkorea gefertigt
[Musik]
hinzu kommt dass immer mehr leute ihren
pc durch ihr handy ersetzen uns setzt
wenn sie einen pc oder mac haben
brauchen sie immer weniger festplatte
speichert da sie doch all die wichtigen
daten fotos und dokumente und so weiter
gar nicht mehr lokal speichern sondern
in der cloud märkte etwas was glaubt ihr
denn worauf diese riesigen mengen an
daten in den cloud gespeichert werden
nicht mehr auf noch karten das kann ich
euch garantieren so lange festplatten
nämlich immer noch günstiger langlebiger
und zuverlässiger sind als ssds werde
sie für cloud-anbieter die erste wahl
bleiben was die ausstattung ihrer
gigantischen rechenzentren angeht und
diese benötigen riesige mengen an
derartigen speichermedien und heute
können wir davon ausgehen dass dies noch
lange so bleiben sie denn während
festplatten aus thailand pro gigabyte
kosten muss man für ssds 40 cent pro
gigabyte auf den tisch legen das heißt
zehn mal so viel wenn ihr also ein cloud
based betreiber wird in was würdet ihr
wohl eher investieren um auf dem hart
umkämpften markt auch preislich
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben
teil eins exportschlager festplatten
oder doch eher ssds aus china und
südkorea nun diese frage beantwortet
sich eigentlich von selbst und daher
konnten wir im rahmen des cloud booms
der vergangenen jahre viele meldungen
wie diese verlegen
sicher gehört in den nächsten fünf
jahren 470 millionen dollar in thailand
investieren heute erst 2014
sie gerät wird ein neues gebäude bauen
das 2016 in betrieb gehen wird das neue
gebäude wird die anlage in korea bereits
jetzt sieger jetzt größtes werk für die
herstellung von festplatten um 49
prozent erweitern und etwas 2500
arbeitsplätze schaffen sagte jeffrey
neigert senior vice president und global
head of operations
tja jedes hochgeladene video auf youtube
jedes neue enorm großen hintern foto von
kim kardashian und jede deiner digital
festgehalten urlaubserinnerungen
verbraucht eine menge speicher auf den
festplatten der cloud rechenzentren und
mit jedem neuen verbrauchten bald
klingeln in thailand kasten aber das ist
nicht die einzige gute nachricht für
thailand mit einem bereits etablierten
netzwerk von technologie unternehmen ist
es leicht andere branchen für ihre
ansiedlung im land zu gewinnen in den
1960 er jahren hatte thailand bereits
verträge mit einigen automobilfirmen
heute stellt thailand mehr fahrzeuge her
als jedes andere land in ganz
südostasien mitsubishi liefert seien
vier millionen fahrzeuge aus thailand
aus bangkok post 2010
im jahr 2014 beschäftigten japanischen
unternehmen 700.000 thailändische
arbeitnehmer das ist etwa ein prozent
der bevölkerung und allein im jahr 2012
investierten japanische unternehmen elf
milliarden dollar enthalten
[Musik]
aber moment mal denn hinter dem üblichen
smog schleier der thailändischen
industrie metropolen herrscht nicht nur
alte sonne scheint die sache ist die
ihre produkte wahrscheinlich produkte
die ihr täglich benutzt werden in
thailand hergestellt aber wer ist so in
der lage mir die namen irgendwelcher
thailändischen firmen zu nennen und nein
dein lieblings massagesalon die ecke
interessiert uns nicht denkt noch mal
drüber nach immer noch nichts
du bist nicht wirklich selber schuld
denn alle produkte auf denen du mal das
label made in thailand gesehen hast
tragen wahrscheinlich die marken eines
japanischen südkoreanischen oder
us-amerikanischen unternehmens und der
mangel an aus thailand stammenden
multinationalen konzernen ist nicht das
einzige problem dort sehen wir uns das
mal etwas näher ab eine nation am
scheideweg
erinnert ihr euch an die ganzen puschel
von den ich euch ein patient habe nun
diese gehören nicht der vergangenheit an
der letzte staatsstreich einer der
erfolgreichsten fand erst im mai 2010
statt als die kunde hat die macht
übernahmen schwangen sie die übliche
faust des autoritarismus
[Musik]
drei jahre nach ihrer machtübernahme
schritten die neuen machthaber sogar zur
verabschiedung einer ganz neuen
verfassung allerdings ließen sie das
volk über diese neue verfassung
abstimmen und dieses referendum gegen
mit 59 prozent zugunsten der neuen
verfassung aus nun mag sich das jetzt
wie eine durchaus lohnenswerte
basisdemokratische abstimmung anhören
aber die wahrheit sieht leider mal
wieder ganz anders aus das militär hatte
nämlich kritiker des referendums und der
verfassung eingeschüchtert bedroht und
sogar verhaftet ebenso wie politische
aktivisten die sich dafür einsetzen in
referendum mit nein zu stimmen oder sich
zu enthalten sogar legal
oppositionsparteien wurde formal
verboten eine andere meinung als die der
regierung zu haben die neue verfassung
gilt allgemein als etwas castro militär
durchgesetzt wurde um seinen einfluss
und seine macht für die kommenden jahre
zu dementieren und dasselbe gilt für bei
allen im märz 2009 10 fanden in thailand
doch tatsächlich parlamentswahlen statt
das problem dabei nun nur die 500
mitglieder des repräsentantenhauses
statt im hauptverfahren
dem premierminister werden diese jedoch
zusammen mit dem senat und alle 250
senatoren wurden von der militärjunta
ernannt das ergebnis fiel also nicht
besonders überraschend aus also jener
mann der den putsch initiiert und das
land unter der jüngsten runter geführt
hatte wurde in seinem amt als
regierungschef bestätigt im grunde
genommen gelangt ist der militärjunta
wahlen zu manipulieren um sich darin
selbst wählen zu lassen oder die
kontrolle über das land einfach zu
behalten allerdings gibt es an dieser
stelle einen silberstreif am horizont
thailand es waren hier immerhin viele
parlamentswahl statt bei denen viele
vertreter einer großen legalen und
lebhaften pro demokratischen opposition
aus verschiedenen parteien zur wahl
antraten und auch gewählt wurden
[Musik]
die liebe raste unter ihnen ist die
junge partei user vor was die fast 18
prozent der stimmen erhielt leider wurde
dadurch der autoritarismus im alltag des
landes nun nicht besonders gebildet
blasphemie wird immer noch hart bestraft
und wegen einer beleidigung auf facebook
wurde kürzlich ein mann für 35 jahre ins
gefängnis geworfen nur normalerweise
würden tumultartige putsche und diese
art von willkürlichem autoritarismus
ausländische investoren abschrecken und
die thailändische regierung ist sich
dessen wohl bewusst doch die thailänder
haben in mindestens zweifacher hinsicht
glück externe faktoren halten die
thailändische wirtschaft über wasser und
ihre regierung weiss wie die daraus
kapital schlagen
[Musik]
heiland kühnert hersteller die aus china
fliehen mit 50 prozent gegen
steuersenkungen ganz genau der
handelskrieg zwischen china und den
vereinigten staaten hat viele verlierer
aber auch einige gewinner und thailand
könnte eine davon sein wenn unternehmen
vor den us zahlen aus china fliegen
suchen sie nach ländern mit ähnlich
billigen arbeitskräften und thailand ist
einer dieser orte diese bedingungen
gemisch mit viel erfahrung bei der
anwerbung von internationalen
unternehmen durch erprobte lockmittel
wie ihr steuersenkungen führen dass das
teil an zumindest seine ausländischen
investoren im land hält ein weiterer
pluspunkt für die ta lettische
wirtschaft ist er weiter boomende
tourismus
während im jahr 1967 ganze 33.000
touristen ins land kamen sind es über 30
millionen touristen pro jahr und wenn
ihr dachtet thailand sei auf
festplattenlaufwerke angewiesen die für
2,6 prozent des bip verantwortlich sind
tourismus macht etwa 17 prozent des bip
aus
[Musik]
und es sieht auch nicht so aus als würde
dies in nächster zeit weniger werden
links ist thailand noch ein kleiner
spieler im globalen maßstab ist thailand
im wesentlichen eine großes
gewerbegebiet und ein touristischer
vergnügungspark für einflussreichere
westliche und orientalischen ländern
einer der gelegentlich dem sturm der
machtkämpfe ausgesetzt ist thailand
steckt immer noch in einem teufelskreis
aus putschen und putschversuchen die
thailand davon abhalten ein echtes
wirtschaftswunder wie singapur oder
japan
thailand gilt es im eigenen unternehmen
und international agierenden konzernen
der mit gewinne nach thailand diesen
würden anstatt heraus und das ist nun
mal der preis den man für eine solche
autoritäres und mehr noch willkürliches
system bezahlt wer eigene unternehmer
haben will braucht schon ein höheres maß
an freiheit und stabilität so und jetzt
bist du an der reihe glaubst du dass
thailands der mittelmäßigkeit entkommen
kann und zu einem südkorea im dschungel
werden wird wird es der future forward
party gelingen eine echte demokratie im
land zu etablieren wie könnten sie dies
anstellen gibt es vielleicht irgendwas
was die militärs überzeugen könnte ihre
macht wieder in die hände des volkes zu
legen um dessen volles potenzial zu
entfesseln
wie immer freuen wir uns auf eure
weltpolitische revolutionären kommentare
wie ihr euch schon denken konnte
veröffentlichen wir jede woche neue
informative videos damit ihr wisst ihr
die welt tickt wenn ihr also keines
davon verpassen wollte abonniert wird
das war politik und druckt danach bitte
auch auf das klinge zu holen wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat dann geht uns
auch ein leck und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]